The joe rogan experience.
What's it like hanging
out with those guys?
I listened junk.
When I went in there,
I told myself,
I ain't talking to nobody.
All right,
I'm going to speak when spoken to,
um,
there was a part when they were
kind of lighting the narrow and I,
and were standing face to face and he's
looking at me and I'm looking right at
him and um,
I wasn't gonna say nothing.
And then he comes in and my,
my tiny,
tiny needs to be tight and a
little bit and he cinched my tie
straight down.
So yeah,
I had a wig.
They put me in a wig.
And what kind of wig would it look like?
Actually,
there's there,
if you type up Sebastian Maniscalco
Irishman that it should pop up.
Yeah,
there it is.
What is the difference?
You know,
I'm so confused.
Why did they give you a wig?
It's got sideburns.
I mean,
if you,
if you see it in person,
you'll understand maybe why I have,
yeah.
It's not that much of a departure from,
from my,
my real hair.
But,
uh,
did they give you the option of
growing sideburns and you like it?
No,
they just said again,
I didn't say nothing.
They said you're going to wear a wig.
No,
no problem.
Whatever you want me to do.
Scorsese was like,
um,
okay.
Um,
there's a part where I'm going to
go through a window and he's like,
okay,
when you go through the window,
and I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to a window.
Cause I knew there was
a stunt guy involved.
Right.
But he's telling me that I'm going to
go to the window and I wasn't going to
say,
I don't do windows.
You want me to go to the window,
got to a window.
I'm not gonna tell Martin Scorsese op,
sorry.
I,
uh,
need a stunt guy.
Um,
but then they said,
hey Marty,
there is a stunt guy here.
He goes,
oh,
okay.
So,
uh,
I was ready to go through the window.
I can't wear necklaces.
A man,
it bugs me.
Did you ever wear necklaces?
More necklaces?
Sure.
It's never been a staple,
but it's a,
it's a,
it's a weird thing if,
first of all,
if it's,
if it's big enough,
it's like this target,
right?
If you have like a bill gold necklace,
people want to steal it.
All right?
There's a lot of Nicholas
snatchers out there.
Brian,
I don't know if you know that.
Yeah.
But then the other thing is,
uh,
like what are you doing?
What are you doing with that big
old shiny thing around your neck?
What are you doing?
What are you at chick?
Remember in the 90s,
chokers where thing and
I used to wear a choker.
How Christmas is like a dog choker.
It's just a really tight necklace.
Hemp necklaces.
Oh yeah.
Those are the little bead.
The bead at the bottom.
The beads critical kind of have the bead.
Yeah.
Multi colored bead
making look at your cool.
Yeah.
Like it's weird like some guys will wear
like little anklets with like beads.
Can they tie them off and they'll
walk around barefoot and you're like,
okay,
hmm.
What's kind of like that
look that they are not shop.
Look where you have like the really tight,
like your pants go up so
you can see your socks.
You,
you show a little leg.
You know why they do that?
Why sneakers?
Those guys are all show
off the sneakers full.
That's what shop told me.
Do you do that Jeremy?
That's what my,
my pants have that actually before you do.
That's how the Pennsylvania,
that's funny.
That's how the pants are made.
You don't buy those pants man.
That then you're not buying pants.
Where do you buy your lady store?
Do you buy,
do you buy it at coach?
Do you buy those pants?
[inaudible] Gosh,
that's hilarious.
You don't do that too.
You know?
How dare you?
How dare you.
Fudge are a little weird.
So I have to ask you,
does Tom talk about Ufos all the time?
Well,
you know he's not in the band.
Yeah,
I know,
but you know,
always do that.
He always did what?
Used to get loaded and just look out the
bus window and I used to do it with him
as like,
I don't know,
it's kind of a bonding experience.
It's like,
if you wanted to show me bow and arrows,
whatever were on tour together,
I'd sit there and like,
you know,
check it out.
So with Tom,
that was his thing.
Like fucking let's get
high and look for Ufo here.
We just sit there and like
stare out the bus window,
look at you fos or like he would
even go as far as when we're on tour,
like let's go and
fucking look for bigfoot,
whatever it was,
you know,
and he would assemble a crew
and they would go do it.
Oh my God,
I never got me on one of those trips
cause that was just two fairy tale for me.
But um,
but I would,
you know,
I'd do that and he was always,
it's really not something he just got
into from the day I fucking met him while
he was obsessed with Ufos and aliens and
was always very passionate about it to
the point where like,
I didn't know enough to,
to have any kind of,
I guess like opinion on it.
I was just very open and,
and you know,
just took it all in,
but nothing has changed.
He's still,
the other day I talked to him,
he's like,
I'm on the way to the
fucking White House Bro.
And I don't ask any questions.
I just be like,
as you should be,
you know,
whatever.
Let's fucking go.
Yeah,
great response.
Yeah.
Good luck with that.
Yup.
Wow.
Long story short,
he goes,
okay,
you can go,
but you have to take this blessing.
And we're like,
sure,
we'll whatever you need for us to go.
So he pulls out the snail shell.
I could show you a picture of it.
It's a snail shell with a monkey bone
and the top and a tube worm to close it.
And in the snail shell is the
green powder and he's like,
this is what you need for the blessing.
So he goes around the circle
and threw a monkey bone pipe.
He blows this green stuff.
And your nose,
is it called the COO?
Hey,
not as like that word that we heard.
I couldn't tell the name of the pipe.
No,
no.
The stuff they blow up.
Your nose is a DMT.
It,
it's coca leaf.
Oh,
mixed with a bunch of a root and
tobacco I believe like all together.
And um,
anyway,
so he goes,
there's five of us in my crew.
He goes around the circle and he
hits three guys and they will go,
Whoa,
my brain feels like I've
got chlorine on the head,
you know,
whatever loads it into your nose.
Yeah.
So it gets really close.
It's got this long tubular monkey bone
pipe and he goes and it just blows it up
your nose and a hits.
Three of my guys,
and I'm watching a little bit nervous
cause like I'm very like standoffish on
drugs.
Like I know things
affect me very strangely.
Anyway,
hits three of my guys,
they go,
Whoa,
you know,
eyes watering and they're like,
wow,
it's a,
it's actually a great feeling.
Gets to my turn
in the nose.
All of a sudden I feel like
I've got acid on my brain,
like chlorine in my head.
I break into the sweat,
my eyes explode and I'm
like wobbling like this.
And it 30 seconds later I'm just
curled over in the fetal position,
just projectile vomiting
cannot hold it together.
And uh,
Lorenzo,
this,
the,
the tribal shaman goes good,
good.
And we're like,
why is this good?
And he's like,
he had a bad spirit in him.
If he had gone up the river,
he would have been killed.
He's just got the bad spirit out.
This is why I had to bless you.
Now you can go.
And I was the only one that had hit
like that out of our five person crew.
Everybody else was like,
Ooh,
my brain sore,
whatever.
I was literally fetal position,
feverish,
puking cray.
And I've never done any
drugs like hard drugs.
Like it's just not my thing.
And this thing just hit
me like a ton of brick.
But,
so the Liam Neeson thing,
and you know,
forgive me if I,
if there's some detail that has
come out that I'm not aware of,
but my understanding of it is he,
you know,
he had a friend who was raped and
then he reported this state of mind,
this murderous state of mind he was
in where he was walking around with,
I think he calls it a a,
that's a British word for like,
uh,
it's like,
a small metal club.
Right?
Um,
there's like a black jack
or like another term for it,
I think.
And I'm looking for a black eye to kill a,
you know,
like,
it doesn't hoping someone's going to come
out of the woodwork and threatened him
so that he could kill this guy in this
act of instrumental violence because his
friend had been raped by a black guy.
Right.
Just like any black guy will do.
Now.
That's,
that's sort of like the,
the extra horrific wrinkle
to the story right now.
And he's confessing this as a kind of
a symptom of transient mental illness,
at least as far as I know.
It was like,
Hey,
he's horrified by the fact that
he was in the state of mind.
Right.
Can you imagine like the Liam Neeson,
that an actor?
Uh,
I have everything to lose and
although I don't remember why,
at what point in his life
he said this happened.
Um,
can you imagine that?
I was in the state of mind.
Right?
And this is,
as you say,
an all too honest disclosure,
but it is damn interesting.
Right?
And it is the kind of thing that
we should be able to talk about.
Right?
And it's not,
and the fact that this is becoming
synonymous with racism seems just wrong
given,
given how he's,
he described,
or at least how I've,
I've heard this because he's saying,
listen,
if this had been an Armenian guy
or an Italian or a Japanese guy,
I'd be looking for one of them.
Right?
I mean,
what,
what this,
at least on his talent is the
virus of instrumental violence.
I mean,
the vi the virus of like,
this is how every blood feud ever
in human history gets started.
It's like you,
like someone from your
tribe killed my brother.
And now what I want to do is
kill anyone from your tribe.
Right?
Doesn't matter who.
Right.
And,
and that's,
you know,
clearly as toxic as it gets,
ethically.
But that's not racism.
Right?
That's just,
that is that we have a word for it.
It's in,
it's instrumental violence.
Um,
but you know,
yeah.
Obviously he's getting
totally pilloried over this.
Uh,
but we need,
we just need to figure out how to talk
about how people can redeem themselves
once something this unsavory is,
is revealed about their past,
whether they reveal it
or whether it's just,
you know,
found out about [inaudible].
What people don't seem to realize when
it comes to history is that when you read
about World War II,
we've condensed all the highlights into
a very short paragraph or a series of
paragraphs.
And you don't realize the
war was several years.
There were periods where nothing happened,
right?
I was in Egypt during
the second revolution.
You could look down and you could
see Tahrir Square people screaming,
laser pointers,
helicopters,
Apaches.
And they announced in the news,
we've just,
we've deposed the
president two blocks away.
A dude's eating a cheeseburger at
Mcdonald's watching a football match as if
nothing's happening.
So when you look at the street battles,
the political violence,
when you look at the,
the,
the bias Banning's you look at the dude,
there was a guy who fired a couple of
rounds at a police officer and Eugene,
Oregon and some bombs got planted at the
police department or somebody planted
bombs that a statue in Houston.
It starts to feel like there's some kind
of political violence that is bubbling
up that can't be mended at this point.
And a lot of this comes from the
suppression that we're talking about where
people don't feel like they have a voice
or that voice is being suppressed by an
opposing ideologies,
you know?
Yes.
But it is really complicated and it's,
it's,
I,
I can't claim to know
how everything happens,
but what I will say is I believe social
media is responsible for the political
violence.
I believe it's,
uh,
it's not just about suppression.
It's you,
you look at,
um,
the systems that were built Facebook,
right?
What content can make it to the
front page of your Facebook posts,
of your Facebook profile.
When you're looking at your
newsfeed while Twitter,
Facebook has to build an algorithm
to determine what matters.
Most companies then figure out how to
manipulate that algorithm to get that
content in front of you.
Because you know,
at most even see what
three posts on Facebook.
So what happens is early on,
companies quickly found out that anger
drives the most shares of any emotion.
All of a sudden we see a wave
of police brutality videos.
There was one website that posted almost
exclusively police brutality content,
and it was like Alexa,
400 in the world,
some ridiculously high
number of blew my mind.
I knew Pete,
uh,
someone claims to that
they're making six figures,
writing police brutality articles
because it was pure rage bait,
right?
Content that just shares really easily,
but that constantly being put in
front of somebody breeds an ideology.
You then tell someone,
did you know that?
You know,
white supremacy is on the rise and there
are 11 million white supremacists in
the U S and they go,
I can believe it.
But that's nonsense.
It's just not,
there's not the case.
You know,
the Anti Defamation League and the
SPLC say that we're at rough estimates,
or maybe like 10 or 12,000,
but people really believe that there is,
like at the president does secretly a
Nazi and that he's being propped up by the
secret cabal,
or there's an alternative influence
network on Youtube where you and me or
somehow trying to convince people to,
you know,
this is ridiculous.
Okay.